ви позбавлені поза поні етапу нове для мене
чи правдиві чесно 6
стоять і тут sr2
батчат і лицьову людей цих я дуже люблю
і поважаю бачати так ти кого я не знаю
вона розумію шуя що ви тут розум на тему
конгрес то цілий означає що духовний
потенціал ти їй зала і над звучання йому
великий вся тема конгресу
на ньому вірна актуально і біль вчать для
нашої України я думаю що для всього
свиту
а ви для нашої країни сьогодні особливо його
я поясню шуму про актуальність
легко здогадатися про те, що парадокс
колегав тому що ми є у глобальному us why
this time of з еблище та плащі 1 це 1 ми
можемо про
по батчату 1 1 на екрані комп'ютера
новачку в із знаходимося на різьблених
у різьбленій годині тенах свиту ми можемо у
бутік та година по телефону вати 1 до 1 у
нас та волоки можливості
для контакту аличі прийому ми більше
знаємо про
инж його чи голий так і вираз
близького контакту у нас правді не
дозволяючи нам краще
безодня ти їм шиву
осмислення шивану було велике
популярності в 20 столики та всі системи
з рідних екзистенціалізм психоаналіз
комунікативно філософія це міша
процесу ви говорите і на
конгресі
адже нам олеся критий образ in show all
m20 вершу мосту лети за 100 єн
серце актуальної не застосовуються
benny з фалах затишок нові конфлікти та люди
не розуміють in show
у нашому краї не ми сьогодні можемо вкрасти
його тиса двом а
підходом і до разу мене образу їм шуму
я перший хіт хіт яко і я поважаю їжі але
мій живим і правильним колимага злодієм а
про систему вас вид і і про травень
будницький країни сопить колими меншому
вашому інок шоу і нашому чоловікові його
написано нового друга або нам
нав'язується
zoe поза на нас стиснути
нашим підходом cool та
еньші це дуже
чужі
віддали купу і ось сьогодні вкрадено в те
хі столичних обстановці схились а то
пак і пак і знаходиться піт пресу
самої такої і вези
іншалла ми моєму срубає і все через sus
Ілля наука ви і думка
ісу крима результат цього конгресу
через і яким буддизмі ст
усвяти через t
я тип комунікації ми ви буду ви йому
mesh молодими людьми для того, щоб для
нас нішою в польшу джергу
вставши тен я кого ми розуміємо рівень і
нашої і може but i владно тем
написаним другом я хочу
виду сила серце баба жатий всім
учасникам конгресу натхнення
по разу мене різьбленими мобами і
у справі нею думаю і так щоб результат
еціо конгресу
до помел та почуття в цілому в Україні
noble записи до того часу
коди в корені люди не ми зможемо до польщі
чергу розпиднутий не чужим sea and the
хто може ніби під енсин уварову after
шутер у друга
витаю з шираза чу ван бліда і брати
яскраву